ja und wir wollen wir sprechen über die
situation nach gestern abend nach dem
trial bei mir im studio ist professor
volker kronenberg von der uni in bonn
die zuschauer sahen olaf scholz 2500
leute hat man hinterher angerufen als
den sieger dieses duells zumindest auf
position eins haare ist fragt sie mal
ganz ehrlich wer war denn für sie der
stärkste gestern abend oder die stärkste
ich glaube frau chalet da gab es keine
wirklich großen unterschiede und
letztendlich auch bei diesem ranking was
sie nennen die forsa-umfrage da sind die
werte ja so nah beieinander
wenn man dann die fehlertoleranz nimmt
ich glaube unisono wenn man sich auf das
presseecho am heutigen vormittag
anschaut dann hat man konstatieren sie
haben es in der anmoderation auch gesagt
keiner ist wirklich dramatisch sozusagen
nach hinten weggefallen sozusagen und
keiner hat sich positiv hervorgehoben
man kann es umgekehrt formulieren alle
drei sind sind im rennen was wir ja
erlebt haben keine patzer auch keine
wirkliche persönliche aggressivität aber
es ging hart zur sache und das ist ja im
grunde das was die menschen die
bürgerinnen und bürger und übrigens auch
die kommentatoren ja eingefordert haben
was wir gestern abend so interpretiere
ich das erlebt haben ist jetzt
tatsächlich der beginn der heißen
wahlkampfphase wo es auch jetzt um
inhalte geht um die abgrenzung von
konzepten von lösungen von von angeboten
die die parteien machen und eben auch
die unterschiede alle wollen
digitalisierung alle wollen klimaschutz
aber jetzt kriegt man genau hin wie
wollen es die einen machen wie die
anderen und dann zum schluss natürlich
auch mit welchen mehrheiten
das wäre ja gut wenn man endlich mal bei
den inhalten ankommen würden denn das
ist ja das worauf die bürger nun an
warten dass man eine antwort bekommt sie
haben es gerade noch mal gesagt es sind
keine patzer gemacht worden mein
persönlicher eindruck war vielleicht am
ende das genau das das war worauf alle
drei wert gelegt haben sie wussten ja um
was es ging also olaf scholz hat sich
zurückgelehnt er war staatsmännisch
getragen da hatte ich gleich meine frage
vielleicht dazu erstmal die geschichte
mit der raute wie finden sie denn dass
wenn sich der kanzlerkandidat der
sozialdemokraten mit dem sind der
bundeskanzlerin der letzten 16 jahre der
union hinstellt ist das glücklich
es ist zumindest ein wagnis ist es
riskant und das ist auf der anderen
seite natürlich auch teil der klaren
strategie von oder falls der eben sagt
merkel ist nicht mehr steht nicht mehr
zur wahl das merken die menschen erst
kurz vor der wahl das ist jetzt so und
er reklamiert für sich dass er
inhaltlich und auch vom politikansatz
den interessant nach 16 jahren die
wertschätzung der menschen ja immer noch
für angela merkel dass er sozusagen hier
derjenige ist der ihr am nächsten kommt
er will im grunde hier die
sympathiewerte für sich reklamieren
wagnis deshalb weil es ja doch
letztendlich die andere partei ist und
im übrigen scholz als personen da
vielleicht gesehen werden könnte aber
sicherlich andere teile der spd doch
sehr weit von frau merkel entfernt sind
ob das am ende freilich wirklich aufgeht
muss man sehen aber eines zumindest kann
man ja bis heute sagen die spd sozusagen
wieder im spiel und ich teile im übrigen
ihre wahrnehmung alle drei haben es ja
darauf angelegt dass im grunde keine
wirklichen patzer geschehen und das
sozusagen sich hier nicht schon eine
person ein kandidat oder eine
spitzengruppe absetzte nach dem ersten
von drei und das haben wir gerade bei
herrn keller ja auch erlebt ein
stückweit erweiterung bei den grünen wir
uns auch bei der ungenau da kommen wir
gleich noch mal das waren ja sehr
kritische töne er greift doch die spd an
dazu kommen wir gleich noch mal aber was
mir natürlich auffällt dass sich herr
scholz ein bisschen staatstragend
zurückgenommen hat er führt ja auch in
den umfragen aber armin laschet das war
gestern abend natürlich auch ganz klar
dass
dieses ergebnis dieses abends er ist
sehr aggressiv er sehr in die offensive
gegangen also aggressiv ist vielleicht
das falsche wort also er hat schon ich
denke mal auf seine berater gehört jetzt
muss was passieren
er ist sonst immer sehr freundlich ist
uns immer sehr moderieren das haben ihm
seine gegner immer wieder vorgeworfen
und gestern abend habe ich gedacht armin
laschet schaltet jetzt voll auf angriff
zurzeit oder
es wird zeit aber es ist natürlich auch
hier ganz klar teil der strategie des
adenauer hauses gewesen man hat ja von
anfang an gesagt über die sommerpause
macht es überhaupt keinen sinn auf
inhalte und auch wahlkampf zu setzen wer
sind die menschen mit anderem
beschäftigt wir wollen knackig mit viel
energie die letzten vier wochen
durchstarten das haben wir gestern
erlebt und frau chalet dann geben denn
dieses bild was sie hier auch als
zurecht aufgreifen und was frau berbalk
dort vergiftet bemüht hat der
freisinnige lachende lustige rheinländer
da kann man nur sagen als solcher wird
man sicherlich 1 18 millionen land ein
sehr komplexes land wie
nordrhein-westfalen nicht vier jahre
erfolgreich führen können heißt armin
laschet hat auch andere facetten und die
hat er gestern natürlich auch ganz klar
zum ausdruck gebracht er kann ja
investieren ja war angriffslustig er war
sehr sachorientiert und sehr bestimmt
und das war sicherlich für viele ich
will nicht sagen eine überraschung aber
doch noch mal eine weitung auch der
presse gehandelt werden wahrscheinlich
viele dachten aus dem lager nicht nur
der union kommt man noch mal ganz kurz
zu den grünen zu annalena baerbock wir
haben ja gerade michael tanner gesehen
er greift auch den partner an die spd
die heute übrigens keine pressekonferenz
gegeben hat muss man dazu sagen
vielleicht unter dem stichwort keine
weiteren fehler machen wie würden sie
denn das auftreten von annalena baerbock
einordnen die kommentatoren sagen sie
ist zurück sie ist wieder da
ich teile ich teile die einschätzung
denn es ist ja so gewesen sie sehr
souverän und eben auch daraus abgeleitet
auch sehr sehr angriffslustig
aufgetreten und fragen zu lebenslauf in
anderen dingen sozusagen klagten die
spielten gestern keine rolle sondern ist
gestern und deswegen habe ich auch
gesagt
jetzt beginnt die ernsthafte phase der
auseinandersetzung und des wahlkampfs
hier gehe es um die sache und man kann
sagen als person in dieser
auseinandersetzung der drei hat sie auf
augenhöhe
agiert und und und mit diskutiert und
sich auch eben abgegrenzt das nicht nur
gegenüber laschet und der union sondern
eben auch sie haben es angesprochen
gegenüber dem vermeintlich natürlichen
wunsch koalitionspartner spd und das war
sicherlich im ergebnis genau das was sie
auch erreichen wollte sie ist da den
markt stärken die soziale bilanz halten
und zum ausgleich in der gesellschaft
beizutragen
wir wollen unter anderem die eeg-umlage
abschaffen eine forschungsinitiative für
energie innovationen anstoßen mehr tempo
beim netzausbau
beschleunigung der verfahren
zinslose darlehen für solardächer jeder
der die absicht hat sich in seinem haus
ein solardach zu errichten soll ein
zinsloses darlehen erhalten von der kfw
und konzentration von
windkraftstandorten
details werden jetzt an die jung wiege
winter und thomas heilmann erläutern und
andy jung beginnt ja meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren armin laschet hat es
eben gesagt als ich das letzte mal hier
hat das präsidium die forderung erhoben
klimaneutralität muss ins gesetz
deutlich vor mitte des jahrhunderts es
ist im juni beschlossen worden
klimaneutralität bis 20 45 und damit ist
der beschleunigte klimaschutz nicht
forderung und unbedingte notwendigkeit
es gesetzliche pflicht das hat
unmittelbare folgen wir müssen schneller
werden und ein wichtiger beitrag ist
dass wir so schnell wie möglich 100
prozent erneuerbare energien erreichen
und dafür brauchen wir ein turbo dafür
machen wir vorschläge dazu setzen wir
auf die energie der natur wir setzen auf
marktwirtschaftliche anreize setzen auf
teilhabe für alle dass die übersetzung
von ökologischer und sozialer
marktwirtschaft für den erfolg der
energiewende und wir wollen das mit
innovationen schaffen wir wollen es mit
anreizen schaffen ich will es an einem
beispiel machen wir müssen die
potenziale der sonne energie nutzen